the Joe Rogan experience yeah it flows
and I think like the training helps you
get all the [ __ ] off your back right
hell yeah
right yeah yep especially for me too cuz
like i party a lot and I'm in the studio
till like 5:00 6:00 in the morning and
I'm drinking and stuff like that so to
just be going down that path and doing
that every day but I look crazy I feel
crazy you guys I have to get that off of
me like I to me you know me yeah that's
why your gym is crazy but I need to do
something like that for myself it's nice
to have at some point like that's how I
look at you like the og so it's like I'm
not gonna go do it tomorrow like hey
everybody build me a gym but you know
eventually that's the goal when I look
back I'll be like I've seen Jose Jimenez
that's what me dude you train hard I've
seen your videos yeah I get to work you
work out it unbreakable yeah yeah your
spot yeah that's a great gym he has a
really good gym Jay Glazer yeah he owns
that spot there a very impressive place
he put together an awesome place yeah
yeah it's cool that the team there is
good like I said it's not all about like
just fighting and being you know the
biggest baddest meanest [ __ ]
like they really taught me about my body
mm-hmm they that's what they do they
teach you their whatever your goals are
they bring you you know up to that speed
so it's like I'll wait like 140 pounds
ever since I got out of high school and
I was like [ __ ] I gotta get some weight
they helped me out and doesn't snoop
train there too yeah there's this video
snoop sparring he's sparring Daniel
Sarafian yep Daniel's [ __ ] crazy yeah
I know that guy he'll have all his
fights before he's a tank
he is crazy like has a tank nuts his
thing is like you know I gotta get hit
I'm like all right Daniel you know he's
got to get hit the weak himself oh yeah
Wow there is his barn with him yes Luke
was going at it so he's trying to take
him out dude Snoop throws some good
shots them right there yeah snoop skills
he really does some glad Daniel duck
that one oh yeah I mean oh I guarantee
you snuba that's funny right a lot of
people ever fistfight oh yes tall as
[ __ ] too
at him like that look at those arms yeah
new so that was so haha that Sarafian
that guy's a tank mm-hmm
yeah he fought in UFC for a while he's
still fighting still active yeah I think
he's in Brazil right now he yeah he was
working at the gym for min and then he
uh I guess he chilled out yeah it's it's
anyway my point was the videos it's nice
to see cuz you train hard like watch you
do muy Thai hit the pads you're really
putting him work on this sir yeah yeah
it's everyday thing it's a journey like
you know I mean alarm Ernie Ernie Reyes
is my oshit I got sent shy right there
that was due he was teaching me some
stuff while I was early do I suck right
there oh do you our sparring right there
with one of the greatest more Thai
fighters if not the greatest of all time
yeah that dude was super time he's
amazing yeah he's really good
his videos like highlights yeah you ever
see that jumping left switch kick you
knocked that dude out with yeah yeah
yeah yeah outstanding crazy cake so how
cool is that man you your sparring get
with one of the Great's of all time it's
fun as [ __ ] because like those people
like you know about fighters did the
majority like you said when you meet
them they they're cool as hell yeah so
to meet him and him not wanna whip my
ass or like hey you look goofy sit down
he's like showing me [ __ ] that I could
use later so it was cool well the Thais
have a really interesting way of
sparring some of them do they play right
they don't hit each other full blast
mm-hmm they're like tap and they'd laugh
around and joke around they're just
developing their timing yeah because
they fight so often yeah John Wayne
Parrs a friend of mine from Australia
multiple time world champion mm-hmm and
you know he would talk in depth about
how they would play they just play they
just hit each other just slap each other
a little bit and you like that way they
understand the timing of it but they
never worry about it and they don't get
hurt mm-hmm and they can do it all the
time mm a really smart way to do it yeah
but you'll see guys like serafian he's
capable of doing that you know he so he
could spar with a guy like snoop or
got likes and I could spar with a guy
like you and you can play with you right
everybody just have a good time and it's
fun at the end yeah super fun yeah yeah
how are you definitely seen that a lot
like more Instagram and even with my
trainers will do it like me Ernie we was
just doing that yesterday where it's
like developing the time and it kicks
where it's like you kick me I kick you
I can't you you kick me I kick you twice
you kicked me three times I kick you
once like you said just playing around
yeah and like when you got a good
sparring partner you take care of each
other
exactly all right yeah there's no ego
involved and the ties they do like knees
though they don't need a [ __ ] out of
each other like it looks like kind of
hard but they're just making their
bodies harder like you say for later
because yeah they're used to it a lot of
times they'll slap each other with the
side of their leg - right then really
drive the knee in yeah they're just
slapping each other a little bit so how
many years you've been trained in
martial arts no this is my second year
Wow
yeah only two years that's amazing I
gained what 35 pounds I'll pull up a
video of him hitting pads that's
incredible
is it - no I don't know tell me tell me
what what video but it's all good you
know how we are you can hit hard
you have good technique you turn you
turn your hips and shoulders in the age
you do it right so it's very impressive
that it's only two years in yo I'm
learning I love it when people take a
chance - and you try something new yeah
that's all but you know we'll get there
so how many eight months had you been in
here like you say this is old this was
probably like a year in yes a year ago
yeah yep still seriously though good
technique for someone who's been doing
it a year the way you're moving I mean
there's no fat to your movements right
see what I'm saying like everything
you're doing it might not be the fastest
in the world of the most devastating but
you're doing it perfect and you're doing
exactly how you're supposed to do it and
then you just get better and better from
there there you go but we were talking
about is the change in your physique
right you became [ __ ] shredded right
it's oppressive yeah thank you that's
only through hard work you can't do it
any other way yeah just just work it
and eating I was all oh I'm sorry that's
mine
it's hard to cut that off sorry about
that
that's no worries man welcome to the
wonderful world of convenience there we
go family
yeah eatin like a [ __ ] bro yeah
I'd like forced myself to eat to gain
weight to gain weight you know if I can
just move it around so much I already
have a quick metabolism so then you add
working out to that mmm so it's like I'm
burning on myself setting alarms to eat
really look yeah yeah getting a little
bit more rest too you know any alarms he
eat like how's that work yeah I wake up
and then you eat eat go back to sleep
luxray what kind of father I do a lot of
like like ginger shots and like [ __ ]
like that to help like yeah to read all
of that [ __ ] too cuz like you said that
she could [ __ ] stuff I go why do told
you to get up in the middle of the night
and eat though my trainer yeah yeah hmm
yeah yeah I would uh I would say that
your sleep cycles more important than
anything oh well it's not like breaking
my sleep it's like more like yo eat oh
you mean like you said in a long wait
while you're awake yeah oh I see what
you're saying I've never heard anybody
telling someone to wake up in the middle
of the night need nah no no did hear
that that's why I was weird I heard that
from there was that movie with Clint
Eastwood where he played a boxing
trainer and his daughter that famous
actress played a boxer okay
know that billion-dollar baby is when
that actress what is her name
Hilary Swank Hilary Swank the job when
Hilary think we could Jamie's on the
ball job when she was training for that
I think that's what I read that they
they had alarm set which she would wake
up and mill the night and have a protein
shake oh really
and then go back to sleep again no I'm
not doing that okay no no no break-in to
sleep just regular eating habits just
reminding myself yeah I mean cuz I was
eatin like twice a day awesome just some
rock stars [ __ ] can't live like that bro
I said it's black do you have a
nutritionist or someone who like handles
your meals
meal preps yeah yeah cuz I don't cook
right so it's like they just deliver my
meals that's nice yeah yeah it's really
nice actually yeah yeah because I'm
single so it's like I don't really got
nobody in the house like cooking or
right making all that [ __ ] happen for me
so it just comes - so you can make sure
everything's healthy exactly what you
want on up for you is fresh every couple
days that's a good thing to not have to
think about there yep the food the food
is like a big part of it and working out
is one thing people just want to get big
like you said I'm a well like we were
talking about I was like my embodying a
soul right so the food is for the soul
[Music]
[Applause]